it had thrills
it had heart
it had Tech emotion and above all else
it had consistency why flow show NYC
2013 was the best performance lineup
I've ever seen Drex here from drexfactor
POI sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I want to talk
about one of my favorite flow dance
concerts of all time before we dive in
though I just want to give a quick shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business friend of the
channel Becca beckonen thank you so much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission I have seen a lot and I do mean
a lot of flow Arts performances in my
day from Galas and showcases at flow
festivals two intriguing uses of prop
manipulation and traditional dance
concerts there's been a lot of inspiring
stuff I've gotten to see over the years
but I think it's safe to say that my
favorite lineup of all time was the flow
show New York City back in 2013. for
those of you that don't know the flow
show is a project that works to bring
flow and circus Arts into a more
traditional theater context and mount a
production of flow Arts performances as
though it's a modern dance concert the
flow show has had multiple locations all
across the United States from San
Francisco to Chicago New York and Boston
I've gotten to perform in it both in New
York City as well as in San Francisco
and it really felt like an honor to be a
part of it but of all the lineups I've
seen or been a part of the 2013 New York
City Flow show was without a doubt the
standout of the bunch and given that
we're coming up on the 10th anniversary
of this show I wanted to commemorate it
by talking a little bit about what I
thought made it so special and why even
at the time I felt like I was watch
watching something revolutionary real
quick if you dig content on Flow arts
and POI spinning please make sure to
like the video and subscribe to see more
of my work thanks so much and let's talk
more about this show now don't get me
wrong there have been some incredible
performances that other flow shows
including the one in New York City some
particular standouts in my mind have
been Nikki evers's fantastic inner
monologue performance from flow show San
Francisco this same year or my friend
jexy's fan ballet Fusion piece from the
New York City Flow show just the year
before they're all good but in my mind
what made the 2013 line up so good and
so unique was the consistency of it
every single piece was a pleasure to
watch if not an outright Banger it's
hard to make a lineup That consistent
when you're looking at more than a dozen
acts to fill in time making sure that
each of them is really bringing
something special and unique to the
table can be a challenge but in my mind
the New York show in 2013 really pulled
it off granted I have haven't seen every
flow show but of those that I've seen
this one was definitely the most
consistent that said I also want to talk
about three pieces in this show that
really stuck out to me and that I felt
like really made it something special
these were the three that really stuck
with me and inspired me in ways that I
was not expecting I'll share them with
you and you can find links to them down
in the description let's start with
fission fusion by New York based
performance troupe Enchanted part of
what makes this piece fascinating to me
is that it does a lot of things that I
find kind of tedious in other flow Arts
performances but actually makes them
work in context here frequently flow
Arts performances involve the performers
simply standing in one place while they
perform a sequence of Tricks then moving
to another place and standing there
while they perform a sequence of a few
more tricks here this approach Works
however because the performance is all
about the development of the atomic bomb
and it totally reads to the audience
right from the opening moment of the
performer's breathing with the
accompanying songs percussive vocal
realizations it's made clear that this
is a piece that will be as much about
the locations of the performers as it is
what they're actually doing in those
locations some particular highlights
include this beautiful moment in which
the upstage fan Spinners gradually rise
and increase their volume recalling the
mushroom clouds of the atom bomb or the
chaotic bit near the beginning in which
the performers pantomime the process of
atoms splitting apart given how static
so much else in this performance is this
brief moment of lateral movement always
really stuck out to me as a fun and
understated movement of movement that
broke up an otherwise static section of
choreography I think even at the time
this was choreographed this sort of
machine-like fan movement had already
become something of a cliche but here it
totally works to suggest the Machinery
the bomb clicking into place and of
course there's the climax with a skull
left amid the rubble of the remaining
fans it was really a stark moment to
bring home the realities the device that
the performance explored an empty stage
fading out on just this visual
chess kiss frequently I try to steer
away from the idea of doing prop
performance as novelty that is that the
props are meant to represent another
prop rather than being an extension of
the performer but this piece did that
quite possibly with more meaning than
any other I've ever seen and speaking of
things that I try to stay away from
there's also the world of multi-prop and
the next piece that really stood out to
me does that fantastically this is
reanimation by new england-based
performance troop Fire magic and it is a
retelling and update of The Sorcerer's
Apprentice section of Fantasia if
there's one thing I love more than
anything else about this piece it's how
much it trusts the audience at more than
six minutes long it was easily the
longest piece of the entire show and it
didn't waste a single section of its run
time the story if you're unfamiliar is
that of a magician that casts a magic
spell that brings an inanimate object to
life to be their servant which at first
seems like a great idea and then rapidly
spins out of their control the first
half of this piece is run time which is
honestly as long as many of the other
pieces in this show simply involves
Josette borman's sorcerer learning to
cast her spell and Gathering the
ingredients for it she's definitely
studied a lot of theatrical blocking
because though not much actually happens
for these first few minutes the piece
never feels like it drags in particular
I love that it's accessible enough for
the audience to understand clearly
what's going on while at the same time
including some great inside baseball
gags like her performing shoulder reels
or anti-spins with her Spellbook she
also gets a great solo with a long
string Levy wand that you guessed it is
her magic wand in any other piece I
think that choice would feel like a bit
of a cliche but here it really works in
some ways I think leaning on the
campiness of using what started off as
an illusionist's tool as a prop for a
performance about magic is a part of
what makes it so endearing eventually we
do get to the section where she animates
a steel Golem played by collaborator
Seth Hill who takes to the stage with a
massive Dragon staff and radically
changes the tone and energy of the
performance where josette's section was
largely a route retelling of The
Sorcerer's Apprentice with the same
music and everything Seth's animation
comes with it a sudden jolt into more
contemporary and aggressive electronic
music and Hip-Hop influence choreography
as opposed to the modern or ballet tense
dance that Josette exhibited it is
exactly what the piece needed to feel
more fresh and contemporary updating the
story for a present day audience this
was an incredibly creative use of the
conventions around living statue
performances and I love how Seth
utilizes a good deal of locking
technique to reinforce the artificiality
of the character he's playing here of
course this story never goes well and
Seth's character eventually tires at the
degree of control Josette exerts over
him he winds up to take a swing at her
and she reverses the spell just in time
breathing a sigh of relief at having
avoided her creation taking down his
creator and you know what the
storytelling is crystal clear the prop
spinning reinforces both the characters
on display as well as supporting the
story this was fantastic one of the most
fun flow Arts acts I think I've ever
seen and our final stop on this
Nostalgia tour it's my single favorite
stage POI piece of all time heavy by
Justin and Christina I've already done
an entire reacts video on this piece if
you want to hear my thoughts about it
but the cliffs notes basically break
down as such I think that this is the
finest bit of prop based storytelling
that I have ever seen in all of my years
in the flow Arts this piece uses partner
POI to tell the story of a couple locked
in an abusive relationship Justin coldly
ignores his partner's pleas for warmth
support and contact only to become
physically violent as the piece
progresses on and everything about this
piece supports its storytelling the
choice to set it to heavy by Florence
the machine the tattered costumes
Conjuring to mind a couple scarred from
years of fights and abuse the use of
partner POI in itself is a metaphor for
the difficulties of a relationship and
how even when you're totally in sync
with your partner it can look like an
enormous struggle oh my God I love this
piece so much it's still incredible to
me just how clearly their characters
read and how difficult and
simultaneously beautiful the story is to
watch you genuinely feel Christina's
pain as Justin both literally and
metaphorically pushes her away and
breaks down her spirit they use slides
and pivots as a metaphor for this couple
constantly trying to find each other and
failing to connect in their relationship
but without a doubt the coup de gras is
the climax of this piece and it's a
doozy after a slow boil that's seen this
couple push each other away and
teetering on the edge of violence we're
given an uncomfortably long pause in the
action before the violence finally
explodes between the couple Justin and
Christina use the fact that a partner
POI trick called the Denver almost
invariably winds up looking like a
battle between partners as as a feature
instead of a bug it's almost more
horrifying to see the fight play out via
POI instead of via stage combat in the
same way that Alfred Hitchcock would
find a variety of ways to suggest
violence rather than explicitly
depicting it the use of this metaphor
almost makes this fight seem even more
terrible given the use of partner POI as
a means of protecting the audience from
it by the end Christina's character is
deeply wounded perhaps both
psychologically as well as physically
and the piece ends in the most dramatic
fashion possible after everything we've
seen Christina shows her vulnerability
and injury simultaneously with a trust
fall a few steps later Justin himself
collapses under the weight of what he's
done
my heart
even though there were other pieces that
were a part of this show that did a
great job of telling a story this one
really stood out to me as high art
because it did something that I think a
lot of good art is supposed to
it makes us uncomfortable so frequently
art is simply an escape a way to let go
of our burdens for a few minutes and
just be entertained as well it should be
I think if we didn't have this aspect of
Art in our lives we would all go crazy
our thoughts and emotions need a rest on
occasion but that's also why art has
such a responsibility to carry with it
messages because it's when we give our
thoughts and emotions a rest that we are
most open vulnerable and available to
receive messages that may change our
view of the world and make us rethink
aspects of ourselves heavy told an
incredibly difficult story in an art
form that works very hard to stay light
fun and accessible it did so clearly and
unambiguously and in the process showed
us that partner POI can be a perfect
storytelling vehicle for talking about
conflict and that's why I think it's one
of the greatest pieces I've ever seen
these three performances were just a
small taste of the many acts at that
Year's flow show it if you can find
videos of other performances from that
year please give them a watch as my old
boss from college would say there ain't
a hook in the bunch I think this
was the only show I've ever been in
where I made a habit to sit in the
audience and literally watch all of it
when I wasn't prepping for my own piece
even then I knew I was watching
something tremendously special and I
knew I would treasure the memories of it
for a long time to come I kind of always
hope that that show was a portent of big
things to come but unfortunately I feel
like that never entirely came to be but
there's no reason that it can't now see
if those pieces Inspire anything in your
own work and who knows maybe someday
I'll be talking about the pieces that
you write with the same reverence that I
have for these pieces and this show and
straight up a big thank you to the
entire cast and crew of the flow show
New York City that year and to fund the
flow arts for putting on the flow show
in the first place
you all delivered something truly
magical and the memories of it stick
with me to this very day well done all
what was your favorite lineup from any
flow Arts performances you've seen leave
me a comment and let me know
[Music]
foreign
this video would not have been possible
without the kind support of all of these
awesome people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helped make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support
if you out there watching aren't
currently a supporter but you'd like to
become one you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and signing up you can
find that link down in the description
or up in the cards if you are watching
on YouTube there you'll get access to a
whole host of awesome rewards and even
better than that you'll be helping me
out in my mission to bring POI spinning
and flow Arts to the whole wide world
and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so go check that
out please and thank you and if you're
hungry for more videos where I talk
about amazing performances check out my
react Series where I take a look at
performances from Mel G give a full
accounting of Justin and Christina's
wonderful performance and more you can
find a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen if you are watching on
YouTube thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
peace